- Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm a faculty member in the
departments of astronomy
and physics at Yale and I also
serve as the current director
of the university's flagship
interdisciplinary program,
the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
I am delighted to invite
you all to today's talk
by a brilliant colleague,
professor Hazel Carby.
And this talk is part
of the Frankie Programs
Distinguished Speaker Series.
But before I introduce her,
I would like to begin by first
thanking our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
who have joined us today
and whose generosity enables
this unique cross-disciplinary engagement
and conversations and collaborations
that transcend traditional
academic disciplinary boundaries.
Also, I would like to remind all of you
that as we are recording this event,
I would like to request you all
to mute your audio and videos.
If you wish, please feel free
to start submitting questions
through the Q&A feature.
And Hazel will take your questions
after finishing her talk.
Now, to today's wonderful speaker,
Hazel Carby is a Charles C.
and Dorothea Dilley professor Emeritus
of African-American Studies
and Professor Emeritus
of American Studies at Yale University.
She's also a fellow of the
Royal Society for the Arts.
She's currently a visiting
Research Professor
and Humanities Institute
Faculty at Dartmouth College.
Her research work has focused
on race, gender, and sexuality
in Caribbean and diasporic
culture and literature.
And her work has centered on transnational
and post-colonial literature
and theory in representations,
examining the representations
of the black female body
and in the genres of science fiction.
Her work engages deeply
with an interrogates,
the discrepancies between
the symbolic constructions
of the black experience
and the actual lived
lives of African-Americans
a pioneering voice and
formidable intellect
in black feminism,
she's recognized as one of
the world's leading scholars
on race and gender.
One of the most influential contributions
to African diaspora studies
came with her very first book,
"Reconstructing Womanhood:
The Emergence of the
Afro-American Woman Novelist,"
published in 1987.
A formidable scholar,
she's the recipient of
many awards and honors.
She's notably the author of
several award-winning books,
including "Imperial Intimacies:
A Tale of Two Islands"
published by Verso in 2019,
selected as one of the
books of the year for 2019
by the time the jury supplement.
She's also the winner
of British Academy's eighth
Nayef Al Rodhan Prize
for Global Cultural Understanding
and awarded in 2020.
Further recognition of her work
includes her selection as a finalist
for the John Hope Franklin
Publication Prize in 2020.
Also in last year her
book "Imperial Intimacies"
earned recognition in the
highly commended category
of the PEN Hessell-Tiltman Prize.
I could go on and on reading out
all the wonderful achievements,
honors and awards,
but without further ado,
I am really excited to
hear from her today.
So onto your Hazel
and we are so thankful that
you accepted our invitation
to speak at the Franke program.
- Thank you very much Priya.
I'm just going to share my screen.
So thank you very much for the invitation
to give this lecture.
It's actually drawn from the book
that you were talking about,
Priya, "Imperial Intimacies,"
which I like to describe
as a very British story.
It's a story of the
everyday ties relations
and what I think of as
intricate interdependencies
of an empire and colonialism.
It does not conform to the
way in which most stories
of empire have been told.
And it questions what we think we know
about our shared colonial past.
I incorporate stories of my Welsh mother,
my Jamaican father, and their ancestors,
one of whom you'll hear about today
into material drawn from
colonial archives and histories
to show how they were shaped
by the times and the
places in which they lived.
But family stories and historical accounts
can actually sit very
uneasily side-by-side.
When I assembled the various pieces,
I found that rather than
cohere into a unified narrative
that juxtaposition revealed
the shards of conflict
and contradiction that familial, national,
and imperial ideologies work to conceal.
I used family memories as a
guide to navigate material
in the national archives
of Jamaica and the UK.
But when I stumbled,
I had to put aside the
voices of my relatives
because they hindered my ability
to see what they had
disguised, what they had hidden
and what they had absolutely
no intention of passing on.
So "Imperial Intimacies" is an account
written from the perspective
of someone of Jamaican Welsh ancestry
who does not take for granted
definitions of being British.
But rather is interested in
how subjects become British,
and how people are inscribed
into ideologies of empire
and beliefs of whiteness that
enable them to feel superior
even when they are desperately poor.
The story of imperial relations
is as restless as the Atlantic
searching between the islands
of Britain and Jamaica.
And I follow currents that draw me back
the mid 18th century.
We won't be going back that far today,
basically, today I'm going to
be concentrating on an area,
but at the end of the 19th century
in the early 20th century.
But the book is also anchored
in the particular places
in which people in my
family lived and died.
The urban centers of
London, Brough, Bristol,
Cardiff, and Kingston,
and the rural landscapes of Devon,
Somerset, Lincolnshire, and Portland.
It's not an exceptional
story about becoming British.
But instead it really
asserts that Britishness
harbors the deepest interconnections
of class and race and gender.
Trying to find your
way as the White mother
of a Black child, for example.
Trying to survive as a
Black child in a colony
and a Black man in the Metropol,
and being a girl who was
regarded as an oxymoron
when she claimed she was
both Black and British.
So I'm going to begin with
this quote by Stuart hall.
He said, "Identity is not
only a story, a narrative
"which we tell ourselves about ourselves,
"it is stories which change
with historical circumstances."
"And identity shifts with
the way in which we think
"and hear them and experience them.
"Far from only coming from the still
"small point of truth inside us,
"identities actually come from outside,
"they are the way in
which we are recognized
"and then come to step into
the place of the recognitions
"which others give us.
"Without the others there is no self,
"there is no self recognition."
So today I'm actually
going to give an example
of how in the book I use and complicate
this question of identity.
The example will be from Bristol
and in terms of the place.
And the example of the character
will be the person I know as,
but also imagine as an have
created as my grandmother.
So all the stories I was told by relatives
under my maternal family's
identity in Bristol,
the West country and Wales.
But I know that my grandmother,
her name was Beatrice Williams.
Must've felt that she also belonged
to the larger world of the British Empire.
And one of my questions is how
was her sense of self shaped
by her environment?
And what did she know of the city's past?
Bristol had been intimately in tangled
with the colonial world for centuries.
So how did Beatrice come
to understand herself
as a British subject,
who was part of an empire that ruled
over a third of the globe?
I lean in through time and space
to tap my grandmother on the
shoulder and speak to her.
As she turns towards me,
I asked Beatrice if she
is like her granddaughter.
If the streets of the city
are her avenue of escape
as they were to the girl.
I make the interests explore
every inch of her city
as her granddaughter explored hers.
When my grandmother had the time
to leave her neighborhood of Bedminster,
crossed the river Oven and
explore the city center.
She would have walked up east street,
crossing the new cart on
the Bedminster bridge.
On her way to the Prince Street Bridge,
which is an iron swing bridge
that crosses the floating Harbor.
She would have passed this street,
Guinea street near the docks.
Was Beatrice aware of the
derivation of the name Guinea?
Once the site of the homes of man
who traded in human flesh,
the Street's name resonates
with associations,
not only to the west African coast,
but to the coin of exchange used
by the Royal African Company.
The built environment
of the center Bristol
still exudes self satisfied achievement
in character and appearance,
the architectural grand jury
and the grace of public institutions
and residential squares is ample evidence
of centuries of accumulated wealth.
When Beatrice was a young woman,
the city appeared to where
its history on it surfaces.
But for centuries, Bristol's public face
hit the ignominious origins of its wealth.
Without exception, my maternal
relatives revered Bristol.
They lived and worked
in its poorest districts
but they emulated the
stilette respectability
of its wealthy citizens.
My grandmother's desire to
achieve a driving ambition
she instilled in my mother, her daughter
has its roots here in Bristol,
a city that nurtured and nourished
the dreaming of strivers.
Bristol had an exceptionally
robust civic culture
embedded in libraries,
schools, museums, and theaters,
which encouraged and confirmed ambition
and profit a sense of
entitlement to its citizens.
Even if Beatrice was
unable to afford tickets
to actually attend a theater,
the library was free,
as well lectures, lantern, slideshows,
and many other public events.
For a young woman whose
working life was confined
to domestic labor, the wealth
of civic life offered scope
for her imagination.
However, unattainable the
city held promise for a future
becoming modern and becoming educated.
I believe that Beatrice
is fierce determination
does send her own daughter to
a fine high school for girls
were stimulated by the flourishing
educational institutions
that she saw around her,
including Colston Girls' School
and here the University College of Bristol
which became Bristol University in 1909.
It was the city's wealthy
merchant philanthropists
and large stable bourgeoisie
that had endowed Bristol
with its libraries, it's
schools and universities.
And with the 18th century
Georgian architecture
of its monumental civic buildings,
broad avenues and substantial houses.
Nourished by its civic pride,
Bristol made strivers of
my maternal ancestors,
all of whom clung to the
ethics and the values
of bushwa aspiration.
If they felt a strong allegiance, in fact,
to the British bourgeoisie,
even though they could never ever achieve
its level of financial wealth.
Only when I became an adult,
was I able to distinguish
between the (indistinct)
and the variations of allegiance,
the multiple meanings of
Bristol in the particular lives
and individual pasts of my relatives.
Bristol exerted symbolic power for them
in its promise for the future.
The possibility of progress
was the realization
and fulfillment of a peculiar
form of British dreaming.
And gradually I learned
to question the foundation
upon which British dreams of futurity
and British dreams of
belonging were built,
promise flourished, because it
was grounded in and generated
by the wealth and the stability visible
in the bricks and mortar
of everyday Bristol life
constructed by the city's merchants.
The architecture clearly was testimony
to British success in trade
to the ethics of hard work,
the value of profit and Imperial power.
Concealed was the source of that profit.
The enslaved labor that
financed the city's economy
from the 18th century onwards,
and which paved the way
for Bristol's modernity.
The enslaved labor that
enabled his Georgeann grace
founded its civic
culture and made possible
its philanthropic works.
Sugar, tobacco, and cocoa were integral
to Bristol's economy and its culture.
The city was noted for its chocolate
and confectionary works
which alongside tobacco
factories employed large numbers
of its residents.
The structures that were
emblems of the city's modernity,
however, physically disguised
the roots of its wealth
in enslavement and continued
colonial oppression.
Centuries of brutal
exploitation of African peoples
enabled the philanthropy
that bought enormous benefit
as well as civic grace
to this English city and its citizens.
The wills family, the tobacco family
became abolitionists eventually.
And yet they designated
the profits of enslavement
to the city of Bristol
not to the enslaved
who had labored to grow
and harvest the tobacco they sold.
The city's abolitionist
hero, Edward Colston
considered Bristol's great benefactor,
built schools, arms houses,
hospitals, and churches
with money that he had
accrued from the trade
in enslaved human beings
while a member of the
Royal African Company
and the society of merchant ventures,
sorry, merchant ventures, I should say.
Colston girls' school was recently renamed
actually Montpelier High School
after this statue of Edward Colston
was unceremoniously dumped
in the Bristol Harbor.
Bristol was deeply
bound to the enslavement
and transportation of Africans
in the Atlantic trade.
But it is misleading
to reduce this history
to the activities of a few
wealthy individuals or traders.
Beatrice and her family
passed by and went in and out
of Bristol schools,
libraries, and churches,
but nothing enabled them
to see the connection
between trading in human
beings and Bristol's history,
its wealth and civic culture.
Impressed by the grand Georgian
houses of Queens Square,
Royal York Crescent and Clifton.
They regarded the buildings as
confirmation of achievement,
the realization of ambition
and success in business.
Now profits to Bristol and
its citizens were enormous,
both from the export of their
goods, to the African coast,
for the purchase of human beings
and from the resell of human
chattel in the Caribbean.
A financial outlay by
merchants of 660 pounds
could reap a profit of 1000%
minus the cost of transportation.
A plantation owner for
an outlay of 31 pounds
purchased an enormous
amount of labor power.
Investment in the trade was
only one source of profits
that accrued to Bristol.
Residents of the city
could reap financial gain
from participation in the myriad trades
related to transatlantic slavery,
through investment or employment,
producing goods for export to Africa
and the American slave colonies,
servicing and Manning the ships
that left Bristol on
transatlantic voyages,
refining in Bristol the
products of slave labor,
and handling sugar and tobacco cargoes
from plantation colonies.
The trade in enslaved people
was closely interwoven
with the wider commercial and
economic fabric of the city.
In the late 18th century,
at least 40% of the income of Bostonians
derived from slavery related activities.
It was not only the merchants trading
and enslaved human beings who profited,
but barrel makers, brothel keepers,
chandlers, candlemakers, carpenters,
dockworkers, innkeepers, long dresses,
sailors, sail makers, and shoemakers.
So you get my point, everyone benefited
Bristol was a city produced
in circuits of exchange with Jamaica.
If the history of
Bristol's financial dreams
has been intimately tied to
the enslavement of others,
it is also true that at
the center of this intimacy
was the island of Jamaica.
In 1655,
all of the Cromwells seized
Jamaica from the Spanish
initiating British
Imperial rule of a nation
that would become one of the
world's leading sugar exporting
slave driven countries
and establishing the close
economic relationship
between Bristol and Jamaica
for sugar, tobacco and the
trade in enslaved humans.
This relationship transformed and enriched
both Bristol and Jamaica planters
because Jamaica was the
largest sugar island
in the British Caribbean,
and traditionally, the
best market for slaves
transported in Bristol ships.
The total number of Africans
who were forcibly dragged a
board British ships in chains
will never be known
and exact numbers are not
available for the 2,106 ships
that left Bristol for the African coast.
are from bear sailed with the
human cargo to the Caribbean.
901 of these ships sail to Jamaica.
Although final inventor is not
available for Bristol ships,
historians estimate that
587,000 Africans were enslaved
and that 486,000 or 82.8%
landed alive in the Americans.
From the 1,591 voyages to the Caribbean,
445,487 enslaved humans
were embarked onto ships
and 3,700 sorry, 371,306 disembarked.
217,263 of them were landed in Jamaica.
I seek a reckoning with these inventories.
I have to find a way to
decipher the apparently
an fathomable oceanic computation
in which my ancestors remain shackled.
Among these anonymous
hundreds of thousands
penned in black ink on graph paper,
are girls and women who
survived the middle passage
and are sold important Tonia Jamaica,
where they will become the
property of a man called Carby.
But justice Beatrice is unable
to recognize the past in her present,
neither can she and Raj in the
future in which her daughter
would marry a descendant of this man
and one of these women.
As Beatrice grew from child to adult,
the most pervasive ideology of modernity
was the new imperialism
of late Victorian and Edwardian Britain.
This was a period of massive
and rapid territorial expansion
for the industrial countries
of Western New York,
who in competition with each other,
sold new colonial acquisitions
and the consolidation of that control
over indigenous peoples in
Africa, Asia and the Pacific.
Through image on spectacle,
Beatrice would not only
have become conscious
of the vast reach of the British empire,
but would also have been introduced
into the racial logics of whiteness.
Did she become convinced
of the superiority of Imperial power,
and did she believe despite her poverty,
that she was a member of a
superior race destined to rule
over a third of the globe?
So one of the most popular
forms of entertainment
was the magic lantern.
But lantern slide shows
were also quickly recognized
for that educational potential in schools,
where they were used
for teaching geography,
history and science.
The head teacher of Barth Road Ward School
in Bristol for example,
built a collection of over 2000 slides
for use in the classroom.
Lantern shows infinitely expanded
the spatial and the geographic, sorry,
the spatial and the geographical
horizons of everyday life.
In 1902, a visual instruction committee
was set up by the secretary
of state for the colonies
to produce lantern slides on the UK
for use in the territories of its empire.
And five years later, the
committee embarked on a scheme
to provide lecture materials
for use in British schools.
But imperialism and the racialism,
which was its primary characteristic
existed in many forms of lantern slides.
In school classrooms in
town and village halls,
the magic lantern shows projected
the racism and imperialism of the age,
justifying the need for,
and the rightness of British rule
in that portrayal of the
peoples of the empire
and of military exploits in colonial wars
in Egypt and the Sudan,
South Africa and India.
In 1897, hand tinted lantern slides
of Queen Victoria's Diamond Jubilee
was shown all over the country.
On the initial slide
you saw at the beginning
of this lecture is one of those.
These shows were visual enactments
and affective realizations of imperialism
watching the jingoistic spectacle
of colonial genuflection
to the mother of empire,
generated patriotic emotion and desire.
The sequences of ceremonial procession
were manifestations of colonial possession
and scenes of general joy,
an unbounded loyalty of the
visceral pleasure of dwelling in
and belonging to what was
called greater Britain.
Local stores, not only invoked colonialism
and their names like the British
and Colonial Meat Company,
but they also signaled a shift
away from dependence on
domestic agriculture,
toward the increasing importation of food.
The home and colonial tea stores
began as a trading association in 1885.
And by 1903, had over 400
retail outlets in Britain,
including a branch here on
east street in Bedminster
where my grandmother lived .
In addition to tea, they sold
a narrow range of products,
sugar, bacon, ham, margarine and butter.
But increase their profit margin
through ownership of their
producers and their processes
overseas as well as in the UK.
The shop counters had rows of compartments
filled with different varieties of tea
from plantations developed
in India and Sri Lanka,
which was then called the
Crown Colony of Ceylon.
Here is a Jubilee handkerchief.
Retail stools with multiple outlets,
competed for urban shoppers
through competitive pricing
and long opening hours.
Although they aimed to
attract the working class,
Beatrice would not have
entered these stores.
She could only stare through the windows,
for they protected their profits
by refusing to issue credit
on which the poor depended,
but there was so much to
see, even from outside,
since window displays
formed a rich street culture
of colonial information and advertising.
The companies that adopted
innovative advertising techniques
with those whose goods were at the heart
of the imperial economy,
tea, chocolate, soaps,
and oils, tobacco and meat extracts.
Biscuit tins, chocolate
wrappings, mugs and tea glass,
commemorated coronations
banned the Jubilee,
reproduced colonial flags
and used celebrators images
of British royalty and military might.
Though the family could not possibly
have afforded to purchase them,
commemorative mugs and
biscuit and chocolate tins
would have brightened
the shells of their home
in the railway cottage
because they would distributed
free to school children
being one of the prime a means
by which school boards encouraged
patriotism in children.
The windows of news agents were festooned
with visual representations of the empire
on which the sun never sets,
including picture postcards
and juvenile papers
with images of colonial adventures,
which were widely circulated
through the practice
of swapping individual issues.
Young people were also
absolutely avid collectors
of cigarette cards.
On East Street sat the large
factory of WD and HO Wills,
the largest manufacturer
of tobacco products,
which incorporated 12 other companies
to form the Imperial
Tobacco company in 1901.
The cigarette cards they produced
were perhaps the most influential form
of collectible Imperial propaganda,
combining visual and textual information
with clear pedagogic intent.
They were issued in series
and blank albums were sold
to mount and display the cards.
There were a number of cards series
devoted to all aspects of empire,
including arms like you see here,
flags, builders of empire,
Britain's defenders,
children of all nations, Indian regiments,
governor generals, engineering wonders,
army life and the Royal Navy.
For Beatrice, as for her generation,
a prerequisite of being
a modern British citizen
was being an imperial subject.
Visual spectacle generated and
confirmed their patriotism.
Their loyalty, not only
to nation, but to empire.
The aggressive expansion
and the maintenance of
territorial dominance,
necessitated war in far-flung regions,
the significance of which was brought home
through public celebrations
of military might.
The return of units of the British army
from the Boer War in 1902
were occasions for patriotic spectacle.
As they paraded through the streets
of cities and towns all over the country,
Mitchell and Kenyon, a
Lancashire based film company
who were pioneers in the production
of British motion pictures traveled south
to produce a film of the
crowds gathered in Bristol
to greet the return of
war hero, Lord Matthew
despite of his numerous
failures on the battlefield.
For Beatrice like many others,
this would have been her first experience
of witnessing the making
of a moving picture.
Death, as you see here,
also occasion spectacles
of patriotic sentiment
aimed at cementing local ties
to soldiers killed
thousands of miles away.
In Bristol, large groups of spectators
were drawn to the pump and ceremony
surrounding the 1905 unveiling
of the Boer War Memorial
in honor, of the Gloucester
regiment, Garrison
in the city of Bristol.
Beginning in 1902, Empire
Day was celebrated annually
on the 24th of May.
And the British Empire lead
furnished schools with flags.
This was Beatrice's last
year in school, actually.
And she would have been among the students
who performed in the patriotic
plays and pre-sessions,
which was supported by local councils
who contributed to refreshment
and commemorative monks.
These were also lucrative occasions
for lantern slide makers,
who would photograph the
children and their activities,
and then sell the shows to the schools.
Persians celebrating empire
were held in Bristol
throughout the decade.
And one of the most spectacular
is recorded on a postcard, this postcard,
where hundreds of children
formed a living union jack,
in Victoria Park.
What did Beatrice or her mother
Rose, my great-grandmother
know about Jamaica and Jamaicans,
other than what could be found
on the back of a Will's cigarette card?
My maternal relatives were
vehemently implacably opposed
to the relationship between my mother
and the Jamaican airman,
who would become my father.
Their understanding of
their allegiance to empire,
their belonging as White imperial,
racially superior British subjects
was formed, maintained and reinforced
in these mundane details of daily life
in shopping, storing
biscuits and drinking tea.
What could have exposed
the history of violence
and exploitation that
bound Bristol and Jamaica?
Beatrice may have noticed a poster,
advertising Jamaica the new
Riviera on a museum board
or in the window of the
Dunstan optical luncheon
and photographic store
on St. Augustine parade.
I imagine her carefully noting the place,
date and time of the lounge and show,
which promised vibrant
images of a beautiful island
of luxurious vegetation, lovely scenery
refreshed by invigorating seed breezes.
James Johnson's lecturing tools
in the UK between 1901 and 1903,
were part of a larger capitalists project
of colonial modernization,
and heralded the opening
of a new shipping service
between Bristol and Jamaica under contract
with the Imperial Direct Line.
Joseph Chamberlain,
who was secretary of
state for the colonies
from 1895 to 1903,
was the leader of those
advocating for a new imperialism.
And he was the architect of
programs for its implementation.
He was convinced that Britain
had to ensure its economic
future and military dominance
through closer links with the colonies
and the expansion of empire.
Chamberlin actually was
the one who organized
the celebration of Britain's
first Diamond Jubilee in 1897
as an Imperial spectacle,
because he understood how
empire could be visualized
and how it could be enacted,
how it could be harnessed
for its ideological potential
to secure the affiliation
and the allegiance of British citizens.
Chamberlain financed a
coterie of imperialists men
in a plan to increase trade
and open Jamaica to tourism.
Bristol was the fulcrum of this plan,
which was intended to impel
Jamaica to become modern
by which was meant becoming
a more profitable colony.
To this end,
the British government
awarded Alfred Lewis Jones,
Managing Director of the Liverpool
based Elder Dempster
shipping company, a contract
to take over all steamships
running between the
west Indies and the UK.
Jones was to form a new shipping line,
The Imperial Direct
West India Mail company
to run between Bristol and Kingston
and open a transatlantic market,
introducing bananas to the British
and the wealthy British to Jamaica.
Chamberlain promised to
subsidize the venture
if Jones would take the leading role
in promoting a new Jamaica and
building a market in the UK.
In the 1750s, luxury items
like chocolate and coffee
were available in the shops of Bristol.
During the early years
of the 20th century,
the British public were to be
persuaded to consume bananas
and dream of Jamaica.
I wonder if Beatrice or her system mode
purchased bananas from a cart
being wheeled down a Bristol street here
by a black man selling the fruit
at two for a penny hate plea.
What the sisters of stood
stock still at such a site,
would they have been taken aback,
where the black residents of Bristol,
are familiar sight to them
so common that they took
their presence for granted,
and African banana skin
dated in fact to approximately 1460
was discovered during excavations
at the museum of London in 1999,
and a bunch from Bermuda
was displayed in the window
of a London herbalist in 1663.
But bananas when not regularly imported
into the UK until 1884
and were not widely available
until the early 20th century.
The closely woven
political, economic, social
and cultural ties between
Jamaica and England
formed an Imperial intimacy
that had been rendered
historically invisible
by the turn of the 20th century.
But bananas were the tangible
evidence of a connection
or perhaps not.
My mother's generation would have taken
for granted the presence
of sugar in that tea
and chocolates and tobacco in their shops
just as they took for
granted the tea itself.
But bananas all imported through Bristol,
a path throughout the nation
during Beatrice teenage years,
and their presence needed to be explained.
The banana must have
seemed such an exotic fruit
at first sight.
If Beatrice knew what bananas were
did she have an image
of Jamaica in her mind
that she unpeeled one and tasted it?
Was a black banana seller
a commonplace site?
What would be interesting
to know about Kingston,
the city from which Imperial direct ships
exported bananas to Bristol
at a rate of 30,000 bunches, a fortnight.
Minstrel shows and
troops of Jubilee singers
from the United States
regularly toward the UK.
And they performed in Bristol
in the latter half of the 19th century.
Here in 1886, the great American
slave troop and bras band
with 16 real Negroes mounted
parades throughout the streets
the day they arrived and
they performed free serenades
outside the old theater Royal
each day before their
show black performance.
What to be found all over
the UK in the Victorian
and Edwardian periods, but (indistinct)
and on the stage in
boredom Hills and theaters.
Alfred Jones also arranged here
for the Kingston Choral union of Jamaica
to make three tours of the
UK between 1906 and 1908.
They traveled to and
from Jamaica on his ships
which in Avon Mouth.
From here, the Kingston
Choral union traveled by train
to tour citizen towns
all over the country.
In 1908, they performed in
Wales and the West Country.
Even if Beatrice and more
did not go to the theater,
they would have seen posters and postcards
announcing their performances.
Confronted by a banana seller.
Did Beatrice hesitate and follow
her brow and concentration,
trying to imagine where such fruit
or such people had come from,
what her curiosity have impelled her
into a lantern slide show about Jamaica?
My mother learned to dream
of Jamaica in her own way,
but perhaps Beatrice also
instilled in her daughter
a particular form of
English colonial dreaming,
Chamberlain and Jones
employed James Johnston,
a Jamaican missionary and Alfred lead,
an amateur of photographer from Bristol
to photograph the landscape of Jamaica
as a space of desire in
the British imagination.
The camera was a technology essential
to colonial projects of modernization.
London slideshows inducted crowds
into a particularly
modern form of individual
and collective subjectivity
forever changing the ways in
which the world was known.
The metropolitan subject
learnt to become a tourist
even without the means to travel.
They learned to observe others
as objects susceptible to their mastery.
Knowledge of the limitations
of their existence,
the misery of their daily
realities melted into fascination,
absorption and longing in the FNS light
of modern day colonies
and foreign landscapes.
The first hurdle to be overcome
in representing Jamaica as a new Riviera
was the entrenched belief that the island
was a site of disease,
tormenting, insects, parasites,
and recalcitrant black population.
In order to see for myself
what verbal strategies
Johnston employed to
accomplish this transformation,
I have to visit the library at
the University of Cambridge.
Searching, reading his script,
my mind traveled back in
time to Bristol in 1903
where I sat with my grandmother
in a dark and auditory.
Johnston advised all amateur lecturers
to tell their stories in
a natural conversational,
free, and easy style,
which would put them in
touch with their listeners,
fixing the attention and
carrying them along with you.
In the dark we are captivated
by Johnston's words,
mesmerized by the glow
of image after image
passing in front of
our eyes and hypnotized
by the soothing voice
which modes how we see.
The audience boards the SS port Antonio,
one of the palatial yachts
of the Imperial Direct
West India Mail Service.
And we're transported
from the gray skies cold
and damp climate of Bristol
to the port of Kingston,
the most important city in the West Indies
set against the backdrop
of the magnificent range
of the blue mountains.
We arrive on a beautiful
island of luxurious vegetation
and lovely scenery refreshed
by invigorating sea breezes
where it is possible to
enjoy a degree of health
and life such is found nowhere else.
We experience a reality so intense.
It renders our lives mundane.
We traveled from the Harbor
to the Constant Spring Hotel
on the tramway of the Canadian owned
West India Electric company.
And once there we look
across the Ligonier planes
to a sea view of unrivaled beauty,
the Caribbean in glorious
tents of El Emerald and blue
and collectively hold our breath.
Moonlight brings enchantment .
We are allowed to sleep,
breathing air ladened with
the perfume of flowers
and listening to the murmuring forums
of the graceful Palm tree.
The next morning we travel
along halfway tree road
where the fields and foliage
just assume a deeper green.
The glare is less than the air freshens
as we ascend the hill
toward Castleton gardens.
On the journey, we are
enticed by the synchronicity
of language and sight.
Crowds of women and children
walking briskly along with
their baskets on their heads,
carrying yams, plantations,
potatoes, breadfruit,
limes, lemons, oranges,
pineapples, coconuts, mangoes,
Shaddock, grapefruits, papaws,
melons, custard apples,
sweetsop, soursops,
roseapples, sapodillas,
cherry moya, granadillas,
cashews, chochos,
tamarinds, avocado pears,
poultry, and eggs, et cetera,
destined from market in Kingston.
Words tumble upon words
in Johnston's recitation,
overwhelming us with a sense of abundance.
We take pleasure and the quality
of that strangeness of the
alien and the unexplored,
the weight and the wealth
of their accumulation.
The resonance of sound and
image produce an erotic delight.
What does it matter if
we do not understand
what we see in here,
what matters is what we feel
the sensuality of excess.
We find ourselves punched
above the mush vegetation
of Castleton gardens
Jamaica's famous botanical garden looking
down upon a public footpath.
There is a mountain in the distance.
The perspective exaggerates
the size of the foliage
and the vegetation while dwarfing,
the human and the social.
Our eyes follow a path of light
from our high vantage point
to a man and a woman standing apart
where the paths converge
surrounded by palms,
pines, and banana trees
that diminish them.
Behind the man in a white shirt,
a tree cost's a solid shadow
diagonally across the path.
We start with defined
another person almost
but not quite hidden in DAP would shame.
A shadow delineates the
folds of the woman's skirt
and runs into the ground.
We have the impression that these people
are as rooted in place as the
enormous trunks of the trees
which tower over them.
We experience Castleton gardens
both as a study of detail
and as a curious absence of detail.
We're unable to distinguish any
of the features of a human face,
but the palm forms a
sharply defined etched
in sharp contrast of light and dark.
We then find ourselves that's a lily pond
where to Northern eyes, the
abundance and productivity
of the natural world
verges on the alien chaotic
and out of control like
the sinister landscape
of HG Wells is scientific romance,
the Island of Dr. Moreau.
Johnston becomes aware of our discomfort
and our fearfulness ripples
through the auditorium
as we shifted our seats,
lower our eyes and lose concentration.
Beatrice does not know what
to make of what she sees and feels.
It's all too overwhelming.
I leave the auditorium and my grandmother
and forced myself back
to the university library
and the script in front of me.
Johnston reasserted control at the point
where the unknown seemed too strange,
too wild for his audience.
His lecture belonged to a
larger modernist project
to teach the British,
to view Jamaica as a well-ordered
domesticated landscape
brimming with picturesque places.
So he counted that unease
by setting his audience down
by the cave river for a picnic.
The lecture struck a canny balance
between thrilling his
listeners and offering comfort
and reassurance regularly reminding them
that Jamaica was a benign
and a healthful paradise.
One of the fairest countries
in the habitable earth,
a land of picturesque
views and unrivaled beauty.
In his lecture, the phrase,
in what other country
could you find was repeated many times.
Jamaica, the audience constantly
assured was a dream land.
Jamaicans are revealed to be gardens,
purveyors of abundance,
barriers of the islands
agricultural riches
for the dreamers consumption,
presented in the neat
clean a tire that everyone
in Edwardian Britain would recognize
as the uniform servants.
These Jamaicans are
posed with yams, bananas
and an husk coconuts.
As they hold balance and lift interview
gigantic examples of produce.
Viewers have reassured that
Jamaicans successfully handle
nature that otherwise could
appear to be out of control.
Offering up to the viewer
the fruits of their labor
and the island,
Jamaicans become people
who like the landscape
against which they are posed are managed,
tamed and domesticated.
The population of the new Jamaica is safe,
willing and eager to
serve their islands bounty
to future tourists.
Johnston and his flickering images
held his audience spellbound.
This picture exhibits not only fair types
of the ordinary domestic servant in turn,
but also good specimens of
the Jamaican staff of life,
the (indistinct)
leaving even Jamaicans
and Jamaican produce
seamlessly together.
Johnston's voice rose
his head swept the Roman,
his eyes sought to make direct contact,
sorry, sought to make direct contact
with each member of his audience,
pausing for effect
before dickering Jamaica
to be the brightest jewel
in the British crown.
If Beatrice a system mode,
my great-grandmother rose were
among Johnston's audience,
they would have learned
that very poor and
female though, they were,
they owned Jamaica land
people and produce.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Hazel
for that absolutely wonderful talk.
I guess I would like to applaud
on behalf of the audience.
- Thank you.
- And I guess we are
ready for any questions
from the audience.
Please go ahead and type
them in the Q&A panel
that appears on your screen.
- I do have one question I
can share from a participant,
I believe who had to leave earlier.
- Please go ahead Ty Kamp.
- Sure.
Let's see.
So he had noted, he taught African history
in the Yale history
department in the late 1980s,
and then some years later,
African ethnography and anthropology.
He said some of us have been working
for the last 50 years or so
on the history in ethnography
of what was known in west
Africa as the Bristol coast.
There is a portion to the west
of the Gold Coast at the time
corresponding to what is
today, the ivory coast.
He asks then, has your work
on Bristol's history extended
to the Bristol coast in west Africa?
- No, not other than just the
extraction of forced labor.
Not actually in detail
to the coast itself,
other than in my research,
obviously to come across the
ways in which the ecology
and the environment of the
coast was drastically changed.
Not only because the instruction
of so many millions of people,
but also because of
the way the environment
and the ecology had to
change to feed people
and not only the forced labor,
but also the sailors and the
ships that were coming in.
So the actual sort of growing of food
to support those forts, for example,
did change the ecology and
the environment drastically.
But my book actually
concentrates on the relation
between the two islands
of Britain and Jamaican.
- So Hazel, I had a question if I may.
I was curious about the construction
of the native of the other
and how that sort of
fundamentally seems different
for the enslaved transported peoples
versus the colonials
for the Imperial state
established in India, for example.
So the sort of the construction
of who is the other,
obviously it's informed by very different
sort of power dynamics,
still of domination,
but domination versus enslavement.
So I was curious how you would
see sort of the reflection
of the sorts of power dynamics,
how different are they in
places like Southeast Asia,
like India, for example,
the British colonial kind of-
- Within Indian?
You want me to talk about within India or,
I mean, because, okay so,
the book actually, it starts
in post World War II Britain,
and goes all the way back to Jamaica
and then ending up in Britain again,
in the middle of the 18th century.
And the relations, the entanglements
are concentrated in those areas.
But in each of those
different historical moments,
you can see different
formations of the way
in which empire Jamaica
being the main focus
actually comes home.
So, during World War II, for example,
the policing of bodies was
very much about black bodies
and white bodies within the Metropol.
And one of the crises that I look at
was actually the brown baby crises.
They called it a crisis, it
was a sort of moral panic.
And that was very much
focused on the children
who were born of Black American,
troops who were based in Britain
and people who came from
the West Indies basically.
And that was their great fear.
It wasn't actually during World War II,
a fear from the Indian
subcontinent so much.
I think because there weren't
so many troops based there.
It's all about, so, okay.
So one of the empire is the way
in which it managed all
its populations, right,
all over the globe.
I mean, I talk a lot about
how Winston Churchill
said that Britain stood alone, right?
After, I guess Nazi Germany,
which was a completely absurd thing
because they had this huge empire
and it was an extraordinary war machine.
- Right.
- Where you were is very,
very interesting, I think,
in terms of their management
of different peoples
is actually in the west end is themselves,
I mean, post-war Britain is somebody else,
but in the West Indies
themselves after emancipation,
which wasn't actually
an emancipation, right?
1834 to '38.
A number of people who have
been on the plantations,
working on the plantations
descendants of Africans,
walked away from the plantations.
And that led to the British again,
manipulating that population
and importing
- Indentured labor.
- On the same ships that they'd used
for the enslaved indentured
labor from India.
And in fact, labor from China.
There you see new racial
formations developing
and a whole new language
and a whole new sort of bio politics
and disciplining of bodies
for certain bodies to be
doing certain forms of labor
and occupying certain forms of position.
And so from that point
of view, the West Indies
is actually really, you know, horrific,
but also interesting in
terms of what it actually,
- It's very revealed.
- Reveals about the British empire.
In the Metropol after World War II,
basically what happens
in terms of movements of my generation
to become Black British
is actually an Alliance.
So, the black movement in Britain
is very different to the
black movement in the US.
Because populations from the Indians,
particularly the Indian sub-continent
and from the West Indies become allied
under that term black.
Again, and so the anti-racist movement,
the Black led anti-racist movement
has that sort of Alliance.
- Right, and I guess-
- Historical moment is different.
There isn't a general answer.
- And then you're right.
And I think that it's this Alliance
between the immigration from south Asia
that kind of formed this Alliance
with the flow of people from
the West Indies in England,
that Alliance, right, yeah,
that alignment has been very different
from the United States, the organization
and the power politics
in the United States
- And they dwell on those differences,
because it goes back to that question
by identity with which I began.
People think sort of
identity as something simple
that they carry around with them.
But I very carefully look
at very different historical moments
and how that in fact is formed
and especially working
with students in the US,
you have to explain to them
that black doesn't mean the same thing
in different parts of the world.
Race doesn't mean the same thing
in different parts of the
world at different moments.
You have to sort of study
how it's articulated
in particular places and particular times
and how it's resisted too.
- And the fact, I think,
and am I right in taking
away the point that,
and this idea of identity
is not stable either
because you reflect off
others and depending on
where the lines are drawn
and how the lines have
drawn, as long as the other,
your identity gets, it's very fluid,
it gets reshaped all the time.
- Exactly.
- But I think the thing that
you wonderfully point out
is that somehow with
all the shape shifting
the power politics has
remained very steady
and fixed, right?
- With the power politics actually forms
the hegemonic power politics can shift.
But the question of subordination,
we're still dealing with the aftermath
of settler colonialism.
So, an imperialism and
how those things work
their way through a very
important to understand.
Absolutely.
- Yeah, and I think that work
like yours is extremely timely
because at this moment right in my field,
if you look at what's happening
in space sciences now,
we as a human species are still not able
to break out of this
of settler colonialism
when we talk about landing on Mars,
exploring the universe, et cetera, right?
I mean, we are not able
to break that frame.
It's a fundamental
relationship with nature
and other beings that we
really need to disrupt this.
- Well, yes, 'cause in my new project,
which is just sort of rather different.
That's sort of also exactly the point.
I mean, the point about
understanding settler colonialism
is that yes, it's the
domination of indigenous peoples
of the enslavement of peoples,
but it's also the domination
of the environment,
and the exploitation of various ecologies.
So it's actually understanding
that settler colonialism
is also itself behind this
extraordinary environmental
and catastrophic climate
crisis that we are facing.
Absolutely.
- Are there any other questions?
Ty do you see any other questions?
- Priya, no, I think
everyone has been enjoying
this very informative exchange
between the two of you.
- Oh, I mean, there's so
much to learn from Hazel.
I could keep asking more,
but let me give a little bit of space
for people to a BiPAP and ask.
- One of the things that one
of the things I did want to say
is that when I actually
located the archives
and found out who the owner was
of those enslaved that you
saw in that slave register.
I also was asking some
very similar questions
because he actually turned out
to be the son of a carpenter.
He went into the British army and desserts
when he's actually in Jamaica.
But again, I try to think
about how he had to learn
to become a white man in a colony
how he actually had to learn
and adapt to the extraordinary
power he was given,
the right to brutalize, the right to rape
because of his white skin.
And so, those historical
circumstances were very different
to those of a grandmother in Bristol,
but thinking about how
people's environment
and how they engage with that,
how what the question of whiteness,
again, is something
that is taught to people
and that they actually adopt.
And then they actually have
to sort of practice it.
- Right.
- One of the reasons I actually decided
to think about this particular
aspect of the book tonight
and about the question of whiteness
is in fact because of what
we've been facing where I live
right here in Guilford
which was a white supremacist attempt
to take over the board of education.
And we had the elections
yesterday and thank God that
because people were very well organized.
They actually lost two to
one, but it is a strategy
that is in fact, very, very prominent now.
And Guilford was being used
as a way to sort of test
how this sort of extremism
of how these senses
of whiteness being under threat (chuckles)
because this sort of
multicultural curriculums
can actually be used
to mobilize white
supremacist politics now.
And I think we don't talk
about whiteness enough.
(indistinct).
- Yes, and I think it's resilience,
this concept is survived.
As you said, it mutates a
little bit, but it's surfaces
any where there's little
bit of room and its surfaces
and there is resonance.
The scary part is that
there is resonance even now
when we believe there's
a lot more awareness.
So there's a very nice
question from Megan Fountain
who was asking,
"Did you take any inspiration from novels
"as well as from the historical archives?"
- Yes, the book is full in fact have
sort of various explicit and less explicit
nuanced to novels,
absolutely particular enemy writers
like Michael Under
Archie, and Kaz Phillips,
actually even Jane Austen.
I talk about a lot and Virginia Wolf.
But in terms of trying to deal with people
who didn't need records,
whose records weren't in the archives,
the archives is full of
the records of the wealthy,
those who write diaries,
write the plantation records or whatever,
but when you're dealing
with massive silences,
it's that case of sort of translating
some very complex historical research
into ways in which a reader can
imagine the lives of people,
and that is where novelists
actually extraordinary,
especially novelists who
really think seriously
about history like Under
Archie and Kaz Phillips, yes.
- And there's another question
from Mary Marshall Clark,
what about Andrea Levy, "The Long Song?"
- All of Andre Levy's
work, I mean, I have read,
I'm deeply indebted to, absolutely.
Yeah.
And particularly, you
know in the World War II,
I think the way in which she
talks about the relationship
between White women and
Black military personnel
is it extraordinarily revealing
Yeah, absolutely.
- Are there any other questions
- I don't see any further-
- Okay, before we close,
I'm really tempted to
ask one more question,
Hazel, if I may.
How do you see this,
I don't want to use
the word reconciliation
because I have to say there
are days when I'm optimistic
and there are days when I'm not.
So, how do you see the way forward?
How are we going to settle
these issues of identity, power relations,
we all aspire for equity
and equality of opportunity
and all of that.
So how are we really going to,
how are we gonna transcend all of this?
Can we?
- Oh, Priya, if I may
had the answer to that.
I mean, heavens above.
(both laughing)
It's what some of us are
struggling for every single day,
in our work, in our
research, in our politics,
there is no simple reconciliation.
I mean, there has to be
a massive transformation,
I think, of imagination.
And the number of people,
a number of historians,
filmmakers artists,
because I think visual art
is also very, very important
trying to accomplish that,
particularly a number of
sort of indigenous writers
like Roxanne Dumble or Teas
and Nick Estes or whatever,
and Raul Peck's New Series,
exterminate the bruits.
We have to completely radically understand
the way in which particularly,
this country, the Americas,
so profoundly still
shaped by stolen lands,
the decimation of indigenous peoples,
the absolute ignorance because
we really need to recover
a lot of those lost knowledges
that settler colonialism
decided, that we're worthless,
whether it's about the
environment, the ecology,
others way to live, but the indebtedness,
the deep indebtedness to the horrors
that settler colonialism understood.
I mean, I think we've only just begun.
- Yeah, and it is a
grand collusion, right?
Because in a society
that capitalist society,
voraciously capitalist society,
these are the underpinnings.
So obviously as-
- Yes.
And so the variation of snus continues
indigenous peoples, black people,
they are still live in the
most polluted areas, right?
They are still considered
waste, if you like,
in terms of sort of corporate power,
they are disposable,
they can have drinking water
that isn't fit to drink.
So these inequalities established
under settler colonialism continue,
you can see that in the pandemic figures
who actually suffered the most.
- Right.
- There's no easy reconciliation there.
But I think white supremacy
has to be brought to account.
- Yeah.
I mean, for me tenacity of white supremacy
is what is shocking.
And I shouldn't be shocked
but I think we have no choice,
but to confront, understand,
and completely reorient our view.
And I really hope that the climate crisis
and the growing political
awareness of all these inequities,
historical that resonate
to the present day,
I really hope they combine
they provide new tender right?
That this combination of the way
in which we ravaged nature as well, right?
I don't know, and that is sort of-
- The indigenous presence
at the climate conference
in Glasgow is incredibly strong
and extremely article, I
mean, saying the most, no,
if only people would listen,
if only people would listen to them.
- Anyway, I could go on and on
and would be extremely selfish of me.
But are there any other questions Ty?
Do you have any questions?
- No, thank you.
It's just what a talk.
(all laughing)
I'm sorry, I frankly I'm speechless
it was just phenomenal, so thank you.
- Thank you.
And thank you everybody for
all the support and stuff.
So thank you very much, it was great.
Thank you so much Hazel-
- You're welcome Priya.
Thank you for the invitation.
- Most welcome.